hello my name is Marty Natalegawa and
for a minister of Indonesia I've just
had a very productive session is now on
the geopolitical risk in Asia
interesting because it identifies the
challenges that our region is facing as
well as the opportunities and actually
in this connection I'd like to address
one of the question that had been asked
of myself
namely what are the geopolitical risks
in our region and obviously it is our
region is Asia is facing a very complex
dynamics we have both traditional
problems or challenges as well as
so-called 21st century problems and
challenges to do with the environment to
do with the food security so in terms of
response we believe it is more important
than ever for countries in the region to
come together to work together in
partnership and define willing win a
type of solution to the problems and
opportunities that we all face in our
region